you can have a fast cool beautiful
electric car that goes long distances
but you know lipstick Oh colony on Mars
it's a cross between a Concord and
railgun in the bus times you have to
invest in order for the boom times to
work out they actually think vacations
are too long
mmm they want to go back to school if
there's a disease that somebody has and
its genetic and you could to fix that
you wouldn't need big runways and you
get places fast
I think there's potentially potentially
a dangerous outcome there soon will be
releasing real-time traffic so the cause
will collaborate as a network delete so
why even run the experiment the world's
dumbest experiments he's known for his
controversial big ideas he wants to make
energy affordable make sleek sexy
electric cars and colonize Mars if you
want to learn the think big and take
action you want to learn from Elon Musk
mentor me Elon
what the road says greatest value is
really isn't breaking the the
misconceptions around electric cars
showing that you can have a fast cool
beautiful electric car that goes long
distances and so the next time how hard
is the the Roadster go without a charge
almost 250 miles Wow so that's longer
than any other electric car though yes
it's longer than any in electric car
history in fact the road says that many
world records in in terms of its range
that we've had one customer taken over
300 miles on a trip
your goal stated goal is to get human
beings up there even as the government
is pulling out of the business of
putting people in space why is that so
important to you well I just think about
a future where humanity is a spacefaring
civilization out there exploring stars
is an incredibly exciting future and
inspiring and and and so that's what
we're trying to help make happen you
know I really want SpaceX to help make
life multiplanetary you know I'd like to
see a self-sustaining base on Mars do
you think that's really practical I
think I think it's possible absolutely
how long is it going to take when are
you gonna put your first man into space
well I think I think we'll probably put
our first man in space in about three
years
and when are you going to put your first
man on the planet man or woman well
we're going all the way to Mars I think
that that's timeframe best-case 10 years
worst case 15 to 20 years and you're
sort of on your own in this effort now
are you gonna build the colony as well
when you get there what's well our goal
is we want to be like the we want to be
like the shipping company that brought
people from Europe to America or like
the Union Pacific Railroad or something
like that you know what our goal is to
facilitate and the transfer of people
and cargo to two other other planets and
and then it's gonna be able to pay the
people if they want to go looking at the
at the Apollo experience are you
concerned that say we land humans in
Mars if they in say 10 15 years and then
under Saturn the excitement is done
we've done it and just go and dress for
the next 50 years like we did with the
pole oh it's not something concerns here
yeah well that's why I think we should
really be setting the goal as the
creation of a self-sustaining
civilization on Mars not simply a
mission to Mars because then we risk you
know it would be awesome and cool and
would be a new high altitude record and
you know great pictures and stuff but I
mean it would be
it just it's just not the thing that
fundamentally changes the future of
humanity and this I mean I should sort
of explain perhaps the rationale for you
know why I think is important to
establish a self-sustaining colony on
Mars because I think you some people are
aware of that but probably most people
aren't and in your head you hear all
these rebuttals like under all these
problems on earth that we need to deal
with and shouldn't we focus on that and
and the answer is yes I mean our primary
focus should be palms on earth but I
think that there should be some small
amount that's given over to the
establishment of of a colony on Mars and
making life multiplanetary by small
amount I mean some number less than 1%
of our resources so you know it's it's
not as important as as say health care
but it's more important than like say
cosmetics I mean I'm Pro come you know
I'm in favor of cosmetics I like them
they're great but you know lipstick or
calling you and watch people may have
different opinions but I so I so I think
I think we should we should have that
and because the future humanity will
fundamentally bifurcate along the lines
of either single plant species or
multi-planet species and a multi-planet
version of humanity or humanity's future
is going to last a lot longer
we will propagate civilizations the
future far longer if we are multiplying
species than if we are single plant
species and and so it's like planetary
redundancy backing up the biosphere it's
you know it's we've got all of our eggs
in one basket here we should try to
protect that basket and do everything we
can but but there are some risks that
are just extremely difficult to mitigate
and some which we will ultimately not be
able to mitigate
so it just seems like the right thing to
do and then the question is next
question is what should we do it now or
should we just which should we wait for
some point in the future and I think I
think it's the wise move is to do it now
because the window of technology for
this is open and it's the first time
that window has been open in the
four-and-a-half billion year history of
Earth that's a long time and and I hope
I certainly hope that the window will be
open you know for you know forever but
it may also close and if you look at the
history of technology in various
civilizations you look at say ancient
Egypt where they're able to build these
incredible giant pyramids and then
they've got how to build permits and
then they couldn't read hieroglyphics or
you look at say Roman civilization and
they were able to build these incredible
aqueducts and roads and then they forgot
how to do that and then in that indoor
plumbing but I've got how to do interval
plumbing you know it's like you know
it's just that there's clearly been a
cycle with with technology and you know
hopefully that that's an upward sloping
sine wave that you know continues on to
be really great in the future but maybe
it doesn't
yeah maybe there's some bad thing that
happens and and so for 1% of our
resources we could buy life insurance
for life collectively and I think that
would be a good thing to do there
is there a better way to travel quickly
from say downtown LA to downtown San
Francisco or LA to San Francisco that's
better than the high-speed rail that's
being proposed because high-speed rail
that that's what really got to me to
think about you know is there some
better way to do it because the
high-speed rail that's being proposed
would actually be the slowest of a slows
bullet train in the world and the most
expensive per mile in the world which is
these are not the superlatives we're
looking for have like our internet but
it's it you know I think this it's all
depressing to sort of have something
that's like the slowest bullet train in
the world in in California at enormous
cost and isn't there something better
that we could come up with that
something better is the Hyperloop well I
think so probably but I don't know what
that is
yeah that I want to ride on it again I
think you know even even if even if I'm
sort of wrong about the economic
assumptions behind the Hyperloop it
would still be a really fun ride even if
only one of it ever existed it would be
a really fun plane no mobile it's it's a
transporter machine it's a cross between
a Concorde and a railgun a Concorde and
a railgun oh yeah but you're not you you
know I don't know something else in
there just to make it sound even more
even more bizarre it's cost me in a
Concorde a railgun and an air-hockey
table budget in a threeway you don't
want a baby somehow
okay let's go let's go
well we certainly have a long way to go
before solar is is any any huge
percentage of electricity generation so
the the way we see that at solar city is
that that although there's sort of a an
oversupply of a particular type of panel
the below efficiency or moderate
efficiency panels today the what what
there is is not enough of our the the
high efficiency panels and as you as we
look further you know further out even
just a two or three years out we
actually see there being insufficient
capacity for solar panels which is in
part caused by the oversupply of the
sort of low efficiency panels today
which prevents people from then
investing in the future so it's it's a
sort of a weird boom and bust so it's
sort of like in in the bust times you
have to invest in order for the boom
times to work out and not be supply
constrained two or three years from so
we're just trying to think a few moves
ahead here and also to make sure that
that that the high-efficiency panels are
made in high-volume
but I mean at the risk of getting into a
sort of slightly complicated situation
that the the higher efficiency panels
allow you to have a footprint of the
solar panel so you need fewer panels in
order to generate the same amount of
electricity and the labor costs and the
installation costs and the wiring and
all that are proportionate to the
surface area so in order to to lower the
total system cost it's very important to
have high efficiency panels
so how would you educate your five boys
actually I created a little school
hahaha yeah what kind of school could
you describe for sure it's I mean it's
small it's only got 14 kids now and
it'll have 20 kids and in September
it's called ad astra which means to the
stars that's maybe it's a bit different
from for most other schools is that
there aren't any grades there's no
there's no like not grade 1 grade 2
grade 3 type of thing I'm making all the
children go and that in the same grade
at the same time like an assembly line I
know you know cuz some people love
English or languages some people love
math some people love music and and
different abilities different times it
makes more sense to to cater the
education to match their aptitudes and
abilities I think that's one principle
another is that it's important to teach
teach problem solving or teach to the
problem not to the tools so this would
be like let's say you're trying to teach
people about how engines work or you
know you could start by a more
traditional approach would be to say
we're gonna teach you all about
screwdrivers and wrenches and and you
even have a course on screwdrivers a
course on ranches and all these things
and it's this is a very difficult way to
do it a much better way would be like
here's the engine now let's take it
apart how we're gonna take it apart you
need a screwdriver that's what the
screwdrivers for you need a wrench
that's what the wrench is for and then a
very important thing happens which is
that the relevance of the tools becomes
apparent so all five boys are in that
school yes until when this is from when
you're old they like it they like it
yeah and you want to keep them away from
regular schools no I just didn't see
that the regular schools just they
weren't doing the things that I thought
should be done like you know those two
principals they weren't adhering to
those principles I thought well let's
see what we can do maybe creating a
school will be better and actually hired
a teacher from the school they were at
who also agreed with me that there was a
better way to do it have they surprised
you in a way of their innovative
thinking yeah it seems to be going
pretty well I mean that the kids really
love going to school I think that's a
good sign you know I mean I hated during
school when I was a kid it was torture
so the fact that they like they actually
think vacations are too long mmm they
want to go back to school yeah exactly
there's going to be huge breakthroughs
in genetics and in decoding DNA and and
then also writing DNA
so once you've read DNA you and you
figure out where's the the error you
want it you want to sort of write the
corrective code
I mean DNA is basically firmware so you
know if you incur if there's a disease
that somebody has and it's genetic and
you could sort of fix that and you I
think we may be able to fix sort of
Alzheimers and I so expect there's going
to be a lot of write throughs in it in
the genetics area and that that's that's
here that that's going to be really
really huge
I think it's possible to create a much
better airplane that I have a designer
in mind for a vertical takeoff and
landing supersonic electric jet that
kind of combines would've learnt at
SpaceX and Tesla because sort of SpaceX
we've got the aerospace side of things
and Tesla's got the electric powertrain
side and I think that would be a really
cool vehicle to have in the world you
wouldn't need big runways and you get
places fast and be quiet and and of
course it would be very low cost to
operate and and good for the environment
Malloy
that was also an investor in deep mind
before Google acquired it and vicarious
mostly I sort of order it's not from the
percent points of actually trying to
make any investment return it's it's
it's really I'd like to just keep an eye
on what's going on with artificial
intelligence I think there's potentially
potentially a dangerous outcome there
and we need to dangerous potentially yes
I mean those are movies about this you
know like terminator even if that's the
case what do you do about I mean what
dangers do you see that you can actually
do something about I don't know
well what why did you invest in
vicarious what exactly does vicarious do
what do you see it doing down the line
well I mean vicarious refers to it is
recursive
cortical networks essentially emulating
the human brain and yeah so and I think
I yeah
you want to make sure that technology is
used for good and not terminator like
evil yeah I mean I don't think I mean if
the movie Terminator they didn't create
AI - you know what I mean
didn't expect you know some sort of
terminator like outcome it's sort of you
know like that Marty finds the thing
nobody expects the Spanish Inquisition
it's just like it's it's you know but
you got to be careful so you want yeah
you want to make sure that there's the
irony I mean the man who's responsible
for some of the most advanced technology
in this country is worried about the
advances in technology that you're aware
of I mean yeah I guess that's why I keep
asking what so what can you do in other
words this stuff is almost an excerpt
well isn't it how if you see that
there's these brain like developments
out there can you really do anything to
stop it
I don't know well what should AIB is for
what's its best value you know but
there's some scary outcomes and we
should try to make sure that the
outcomes are good and not bad
yeah or escape tomorrow's if there's no
other option yeah I will chase us there
pretty quickly I think we should be very
careful about artificial intelligence if
I would guess at what our biggest
existential threat is it's probably that
so we need to be very careful with
artificial intelligence increasingly
inclined to think that there should be
some regulatory oversight at the
Internet bigger the national and
international level just to make sure
that we don't do something very foolish
I mean with artificial intelligence we
are summoning the demon you know you
know all those stories where is the guy
with the pentagram and the holy water
and he's like yeah sure you can control
the demon then work out
some people compare the Tesla to a and
liked it somewhat like an iPhone on
wheels is that is that the right analogy
to make I have two of them right yeah
but yeah I mean just basically get some
wheels glitter on your iPhone and you're
good to go I mean it's pretty much the
same thing so it there are certainly
some analogies that in that direction
that makes sense I'm going to do
sometimes in fact myself referred to it
as a computer on wheels it's I mean it's
more than an electric car it's actually
I think you call it that's really
designed to take advantage of 21st
century technology so it's got a 17 inch
touchscreen display it's always
connected to the Internet via cell modem
or via Wi-Fi you can ask for any song
any time just by literally asking for it
so if you hold down the voice button and
say play ring a fire by Johnny Cash
it'll play it you can say play the
teashop sketch by Monty Python anything
you like the most obscure thing the car
will actually play it on demand and it
just works you don't have to do anything
so and you can you can adjust the cause
parameters like the ride height of the
vehicle you can do not adjust
dynamically from the center screen soon
we'll be releasing real-time traffic so
the cause will collaborate as a network
fleet to optimize the route to your
destination that's going to be pretty
exciting and we're adding a lot much
more functionalities to call it even
after you bought the car it keeps
getting better because I've added soccer
functionality that we download to it at
no charge
I have a message for the climate change
skeptics and and the big oil people well
as far as climate change skeptic I mean
like I'm you know I like to I believe in
the scientific method and one should be
one should have a healthy skepticism of
things in general and you know as if
your first things from a scientific
standpoint you always look at things
probabilistically not definitively and
so I think a lot of times if somebody's
a skeptic in the science community what
they're really saying is that they're
not sure that it's 100% certain that
this is the case but that's that's
that's not the point the point is that
is it's looking from the other side so
what do you think the percentage chance
is of this being catastrophic for some
meaningful percentage of those
population is it greater than one
percent is it even one percent if it is
even one percent why are we running this
experiment because although the Russian
Roulette we're playing Russian roulette
with the atmosphere we're playing
Russian roulette and then and as each
year goes by we're loading more rounds
in the chamber no it's not wise so so
that's and what makes it super insane is
that we're gonna run out of oil anyway
like it's not like there's some infinite
oil supply we're gonna run out of it so
we know we have to get to a sustainable
means of transportation no matter what
so why even run the experiment it's the
world's dumbest experiment
thank you so much for watching I hope
you enjoyed this video I'd love to know
which of you on must 10 ideas you
resonate with the most what's the
biggest one that you love the most
leaving the comments below I'm also
curious to find out what your big idea
is and what some of the roadblocks are
that you're facing right now to actually
implement in that big idea of yours
leaving the in the comments below I'm
gonna join in the discussion thank you
guys so much for watching
continue to believe and I'll see you
soon
so I'd like to get inside your head a
little bit about you know when you come
up with an idea
do you doodle it you know in a pad of
paper or do you get your iPad out and
and take notes I mean when you come up
with something you you know a new rocket
design or whatever it is how does that
manifest itself could we see you're
being creative
I mean it's somewhat cliched but it's
happens wet in the shower I don't what
is about showers before yes I think get
the camera I'm just no I do I just throw
stander in the shower do you have long
showers I do wrong but yeah I do the
running man epiphanies
those are if those are huge so yeah I
think that's yeah and then there are
sometimes like late at nights if I've
been thinking about something and I
can't sleep and I'll be up for you know
and for several hours thinking about
sort of pacing around the house and
thinking about things and occasional
I'll sketch something or send myself an
email or something like that